foreign
my name is Bridget and I'm from Camden
Maine I'm curious about decluttering
your ex who is also the mother or father
of your child and there are just some
things that you want to hold on to but
they also make you really emotional
there are just some things that I want
to keep from when my daughter was a baby
and I do look at them really fondly and
quite regularly but I'm not sure what to
do with things like our wedding album
which she really loves to see and stuff
like their baby shower photos and some
of the thank you cards that I put in
another album for her
um he is a part of our life but he and I
don't get along anymore and that makes
it really hard I do get emotional when I
see those things but I understand that
they really matter to her and to be
honest they matter to me too
um do you have any advice
so letting go is not a one-time event we
are always letting go and I think that's
an important thing to understand because
the reason we're always letting go is
because we're always picking up things
now it could be physical things like the
wedding album but you could let go of
that wedding album today and not let go
of it mentally
so it's possible for the opposite to
also happen where it no longer has a tug
over you can let go of it mentally where
it's no longer taking up space in your
psyche and later in the episode during
the added value segment I want to talk
about the Sedona Method because hail
dotskin was supposed to be here today
but he had to cancel he wasn't able to
make it out to Los Angeles and it's
really a method for letting go
internally right Ryan and TK and I we
often talk about letting go of the
physical things externally so we can
start dealing with that internal clutter
and really that's what Bridget is
talking about here she has some internal
clutter it's not that the wedding album
is a problem
having a wedding if it was just that one
thing I'd say you know what keep it
except it is creating clutter in your
life you have X clutter clutter from
your ex the residue of this past
relationship is haunting your current
life and I've experienced this in my own
life for sure and I know my wife has you
know I have a my daughter Ella's my
stepdaughter and so Beck's my wife has a
previous marriage to which she still
tethered because of this other human
being this beautiful human being that
they created while you can really
appreciate that young human being that
child
you also recognize that well now I'm
forever tied to this other person good
bad or indifferent that is exactly how
it is so the question ultimately comes
back to How can I
come to accept the fact that I'm going
to be with this person even though we're
not together still I still have a tie to
this person and how can I accept that so
that I can move forward DK we we often
talk about acceptance a lot on on the
podcast and I'm wondering if you have
any before I get into the Sedona Method
I wonder if you have any any insights
yeah I I think uh one of the most
important things to let go in life is
the idea that you need to hold on to
your pain for the purpose of satiating
other people's curiosity sometimes we
need to move on in order to grow in
order to get the healing that we need
and sometimes other people will want to
hold us back because they're curious
about that part of our lives that we
need to move on from hey tell me about
that thing that happened to you tell me
about why you and that guy or you and
that girl broke up tell me more and
there comes a point where you might just
need to stop talking about it you might
need to focus on something else and
other people's curiosity
they can it can hold you hostage even
though they're well-meaning and they're
sincere and there just has to come a
point in your life where you establish
those boundaries and say hey look I'm
not obligated to hold on to my pain just
so other people can remember it more
conveniently right and so when it comes
to things like photos that you have with
you and your ex I'm not even talking
about the ones with your your child in
them
I don't think you're obligated to hold
on to those photos if they bring you
down just because your child might enjoy
looking at them in the same way that you
had to get over your heart breaks that's
something that they'll have to get over
that's something that your child will
have to let go of the other thing I
would say is
letting go for you doesn't have to mean
letting go for someone else and if there
is something like pictures of your child
or whatever that she might value looking
at at some point in the future let your
ex hold on to it maybe he won't mind
holding on to it and that way you don't
have to look at it but as she gets a
little older she can look at it and then
she can decide what she wants to do with
it but when it comes to the stuff in
your life in your house
give yourself permission to let it go if
it brings you healing because the best
gift that you can give her or anyone in
your life it's not a photo album you
know it's it's a heart that's free it's
a heart that's available to love that's
beautiful right can I ask you a question
oh go ahead oh sure you can ask me a
question yeah well the one thing I was
going to add is you know I don't know if
this is the case for bridging or not but
it sounds like there might be some
feelings emotions memories uh trauma
maybe the like she might want to
um you know focus on working through so
that could be uh working through it
could be going and you know seeking out
a therapist or whatever but for her to
be triggered like that
um every single time what I what I
wouldn't do myself is I wouldn't just
ignore that I wouldn't just be like okay
well this this certain thing triggers a
certain negative emotion so I'm gonna
get rid of that and I'm just gonna put
it out of sight out of mind
um because if it's if it's the emotion
and not the actual item then you're
going to have those emotions come up
some other way or uh with with a
different item so again I don't know if
this is uh Bridget's
um uh problem or not but it's that's
what I would consider personally what's
the question man when I was thinking
about her question I was thinking about
you and your packing party when you were
letting go of all your stuff that's a
great example of letting go because
there were many things in there that
brought you Joy at one point in time or
they still added some sort of small
amount of value to your life but it
wasn't enough value for you to hold on
to it because there was enough pain in
holding on to it and that's what I see
in Bridget's question is I'm holding on
to this thing because my daughter really
enjoys getting value from it but that
presupposes that value is finite and she
can only get value from this thing but
the truth is you can let that go and it
seems to me that you'll find more value
on the other side of letting go yeah and
I think it comes down to what are you
letting go of and why are you letting go
of it I mean if you're letting go of
things just to be a minimalist then
you're probably not going to find the
value that you're talking about there
Josh but yes certainly when you let go
of your horde when you
um let go of things that are like
legitimately stressing you out weighing
on your mind then yeah there is a value
in like letting go of those uh those
objects that create those negative
emotions I do want to talk about the
Sedona Method real quick this book is
fascinating I'm really enjoying it I'm
not finished with it yet but I can tell
you that I'm already putting to practice
the concept in here there are no musts
there are no shoulds there are no
prescriptions in it but it's a better
way of understanding how to release
something another way to say it is how
to let go of something and really there
is this four-step process that allows us
to release and it it's almost
the first steps I'll just walk through
the whole the whole thing real quick
because it's it's real simple and you
can do this right now if you're
listening to this or we can do it here
in the room
there are basically four steps to help
you let go emotionally internally the
first step is what is that one thing
right now that you're struggling with
that's bringing you pain that's causing
you grief think of one thing a physical
item or a it could be a physical item
okay think of one thing though okay that
is causing you grief it could be a
relationship it could be a health issue
it could be a material possession it
could be a career think of one thing
that is causing you grief and just for a
moment welcome it in allow it hold on to
that for a moment it's not about letting
it go right now welcome that grief that
despair welcome it in and just allow it
you don't have to cling to it but allow
it in
the second question here is
can I let it go meaning is it possible
that I could let this go at some point
in time the third question is will you
let this go
meaning
would you be willing to let it go
and the fourth question is when
and that's an invitation to let go right
now you don't have to wait for the
future to let it go you can let it go
right now did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]